there's a lot of physical action going
on in this film amidst all the other
stuff what was the the biggest challenge
for you guys were there any injuries
I mean there's always there are always
injuries
but whether you're whether you end up in
a cast or not doing stunt work it's it's
physical stuff and even when you block a
punch that that punch lands somewhere so
you're always going on with bumps and
bruises and we're all getting older and
so it has it has lasting effects
anything in particular um
yeah any fight with frank grillo yeah
you gotta know how to pull his punches
Mack you must know this now we were
hitting each other for real oh you hit
for real if you don't block Frank
Grillo's punch you're gonna get knocked
that's cuz he's an actual box he's a
very wise doesn't know anything but 100
that's because he's a mean person
yeah so I'll do the same thing Nick Cage
the other night frank grillo beat the
[ __ ] didn't um today I mean if I'm
forever wounded
I'm from a movie I know I know I mean
I'm all injuries from Iron Man two days
and I just keep redoing them that's part
of the that's part of the joy that's not
part of the joy the process I guess I
mean like Chris said it gets you know
you as you sustained more injuries over
time and it hurts for longer and things
like that but um I don't know it's uh I
guess I like to be able to do as much of
the stunt work as possible and I don't
you know I think you take her a little
bit of a risk with that but uh I'd
rather I'd rather that than you know
have to hand off my scenes to the stunt
team that's capable and amazing as they
are all the time I'd rather do some of
it you know
and have some battle wounds that I could
compare bruises and the assignment
Sebastian any injuries I mean you know I
I feel like I got pretty familiar with
Chris's kneecap like once or twice I
don't know that we were doing everything
so quickly and and we we sort of prepare
for months doing those fight sequences
so I honestly wouldn't feel anything
until I was on in the car on the way
home when I couldn't get out of the seat
like being dropped off at the hotel but
I'm sure we heard each other you didn't
hurt me you I haven't even first time
I'm seeing you that's why I said quiet
nice to work with you okay thank you and
I'm Sam you weren't on the end of a
frank grillo punch at any point but me
yeah did you get any injuries on yeah no
I just messed up man extensively I have
no issues with him being hurt that's
what he paid to do and he loves it he
from a stunt family his father was a
stunt man he all of his brothers a stunt
man before they could eat breakfast in
the morning a dad kicked him down the
stairs in the one I made him jump out a
window they come downstairs to get their
breakfast so I used kiante more than my
god he worked more than I do sometimes
why didn't I learn that I'm Sony movie
every day I'm oncoming limping and I'm
like iron so bad it seems like why don't
you let other people that are better is
done it's way better to you know see him
you know you you stand there they throw
a punch you duck out of the way
they fight and you get up and go and run
off and do the next guy
that simple good for you
you